قالت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ان اسرائيل بدات في التحول من
حمله بريه وجويه واسعه النطاق في قطاع غزه
الى مرحله من الاستهداف المركز مشيره الى
ان مسؤولين اسرائيليين ابلغوا نظرائهم
الامريكيين انهم يامرون في استكمال
المرحله الانتقاليه بنهايه هذا الشهر
لكنهم اشاروا الى ان الجدول الزمني ليس
ثابتا وتوقع مسؤولون امريكيون ان تعتمد
العمليه الانتقاليه الاسرائيليه في القطاع
بشكل اكبر على ما وصفوه بالمهام الجراحيه
التي تقوم بها مجموعات اصغر من قوات
النخبه الاسرائيليه تتحرك الداخل وخارج
المراكز السكانيه في غزه للعثور على قاله
حماس وقتلهم وانقاذ الرهائن وتدمير
الانفاق واشاروا الى ان عدد القوات
الاسرائيليه في الجزء الشمالي من غزه
انخفض الى اقل من نصف عدد الجنود البالغ
عددهم نحو 50 الفا كانوا موجودين حتى
الشهر الماضي خلال ذروه
الحمله
ان